more now and all this the rising gun
violence happening across the country
with louisiana senator john kennedy
a member of the senate judiciary
committee it's heartbreaking senator to
see this happening
in our major american cities and it
seems to still be on the rise
what are we doing about it senator
well our mayors obviously aren't doing
enough there are three things they ought
to do immediately in my judgment
number one don't defund the police
number two i love social workers but
don't send a social worker to do a cop's
job
number three call michael bloomberg and
rudy giuliani
and ask those two former mayors how they
got control
of the violence in new york city they
will tell you they implemented
stop question and frisk they used it
as it should be used in a racially
neutral manner
it's a perfectly constitutional look at
the 1968 opinion terry v
ohio written of all people by chief
justice earl warren probably the most
liberal
we've ever had by the supreme court on
the supreme court
the president has said though if those
mayors of those cities that are seeing a
spike in violence don't step
in don't do something to stop this that
he will offer
federal assistance federal help will
will
be offered to step in do you support
that and at what level
should the federal government step in to
stop the violence
well i haven't talked to the president
about it but my understanding is he has
offered many of our mayors
federal help and and most if not all of
them
uh have said uh have said no um
and we're reaping the consequences right
now i mean you you
a civilization to be civilized civilized
has to have rules and you have to have
somebody to enforce those rules and
that's the role of our cops and so many
of these mayors think the cops are
guilty until proven innocent
all right i want to go to the messaging
that we saw from the president yesterday
and obviously the former vice president
joe biden speaking in delaware
the president speaking in the rose
garden went on the attack against joe
biden on his record listen to these
this is all that donald trump and
republicans offer
backward looking policies that will harm
the environment
make communities less healthy hold back
economic promise
while other countries race ahead there
has never been a time
and this is just a few this is it's much
worse than that
we did this very quickly it's probably
never been a time when candidates are so
different
so what did you think of all that
because obviously the
critics are saying the president
shouldn't have delivered a
campaign-style speech like that from the
rose garden
wasn't exactly what was promised but
meanwhile while you've got the polls
indicating joe biden leading
you've got tommy tuberville in alabama
pulling off a victory last night he's a
trump-supported candidate
so what does this say about president
trump's re-election chances
well i can just tell you sandra why i'm
not going to vote for vice president
biden
uh he's a proponent of the i deserve you
owe me mentality i'm not i believe in
free will and responsibility uh
biden thinks he can tax spend in a
regular and regulate america into
prosperity i don't
um i believe in more freedom he believes
in more free stuff
i think the vice president or at least
the people that are going to run the
show
think abortion is a moral good i don't
i think the vice president thinks that
the way you handle china and russia and
iran and north to korea is giving a big
hug and a cup of cocoa i don't i think
you have to be firm with them because
weakness invites the wolves it's just a
fundamental difference
and if the americans american people are
asked i think they'll
they and understand what he stands for i
think they'll see that the vice
president
for whatever reason took a hard left and
kept driving
all right i want to move on to how you
spent your day yesterday with
the vice president mike pence in baton
rouge in tiger stadium
there was a round table discussion even
coach odron was present for this
but mike pence went on to say he
believes that louisiana public schools
should
open even if cdc guidance can't be
followed listen
later this week we anticipate that dr
redfield and the team at cdc will
issue additional guidance
we don't want cdc guidance to be a
reason why
why people don't reopen their schools so
if if the schools
can't follow what president trump has
clearly laid out is
it is almost difficult to follow
guidance in many cases
costly to the schools etcetera open
anyway do you support that message
well here first we were at lsu where you
were a scholar athlete
i used to teach there we had a great day
here's what i heard the vice president
say he said look the cdc guidelines are
guidelines
uh education is a local decision use
your own good judgment here's what i
also heard him say these are my words
not his
uh for whatever reason and this is a
good thing
our kids don't seem to be as
susceptible or at least get as nearly as
sick as adults do from the coronavirus i
think we've had 30 deaths
of kids under 15 that's 30 too many of
course
i think that keeping the schools closed
is going to do far more harm
to our kids than the coronavirus ever
can
now it it's up to the parents i believe
parents ultimately
are responsible for their kids if you
don't want to send your kid back to
school don't
if you're a teacher and you don't want
to go back don't that's between you and
the school board
but i just think that for many of our
children
in america school is the most stable
thing
in their lives it's more than just
education it's health care it's mental
health it's counseling
and we need to get them open and i've
watched you know i've watched
dozens of other countries do it even
vietnam for god's sakes has opened up
their schools if they can
do it safely we can too but part of the
problem is i do think it's also been a
lot
been politicized sandra i think that
they're not not
not there some politicians in washington
that um not all now i don't want to
paint them too broad
brush but i think that they they like
the political chaos of having our
our schools close they think it'll help
them in in november
i just think we ought to think about the
next generation not the next election
democrats obviously are pushing back on
that
message very hard that their priority is
the children it is the safety of
the children so that's a debate that's
firing up as well
but there seems to be mixed messaging
even inside of the white house when it
comes
to all of this now you've got this new
op-ed
in the in usa today penned by peter
navarro
an economic advisor to the president
where he's essentially making the case
that dr
fauci is wrong here's a piece of it
anthony fauci's been wrong about
everything i've interacted with him on
dr anthony falchi is a good bedside
manner with the public but he's been
wrong about everything i've interacted
with him on so when you ask me whether i
listen to dr fauci's advice
my answer is only with skepticism
and caution i'll quickly point out that
the white house has reacted to this the
director of strategic communications
said that this did not go through normal
white house clearance processes and is
the opinion of peter navarro alone the
president values the expertise
of the medical professionals advising
his administration but senator
kennedy does it does it help to have
this mixed messaging and to have
someone on the president's team publicly
attacking
the lead infectious disease expert
advising the president
i know both mr navarro and and dr
falchi i like them both i respect them
both i trust dr fauci
but i don't think it's uh a news flash
that uh
mr navarro and dr fauci have not gotten
along from day one this is not the first
time they've tied up
uh i don't know why peter wrote the
column you know it is what it is he's
entitled his opinion
this is america or at least at least for
now we're entitled to our opinion
i would prefer that he not write it i
was with the vice president dr burks
yesterday
and seema verma and the admiral and
you know everybody's on the same page
i know the vice president thinks the
world of dr fauci i do
is he right 100 of the time no none of
us are
learning every day about this virus all
right
senator john kennedy appreciate your
time this morning we've got calls into
the white house of course
on that so we'll have more throughout
the morning and senator kennedy from
louisiana we appreciate it thank you